a high up Source MGM has reached out to
us and they've been able to confirm that
most at least of what we've been saying
for the last 18 months is bang on yes
yes yeah can you feel that buddy
welcome to psycheck your Sci-Fi TV and
movie channel
[Music]
so first of all if you actually saw the
live on Sunday you'll know that I very
excitedly announced this because I'd
literally got off a video call with the
person minutes before
I got an email on Friday from an MGM
account and they basically said that
their boss had authorized them to
contact Sidetrack to have a conversation
to clarify a few things and to hopefully
begin a little bit of a relationship
with them they've basically said that
they are building towards a Stargate
project and they want influences
apparently I'm an influencer now who
knew to actually be on board and they
want to open up that line of
communication with YouTubers that they
think will potentially make an impact on
this new project they have contacted us
and I'm sure they'll be contacting
others now I have been given permission
to tell you parts of that conversation
I've obviously not going to be allowed
to tell you who the executive is or who
the person is that I spoke to and there
are certain things that we discussed I
am not allowed currently to share but I
am allowed to tell you quite a bit so
first of all they confirmed to me that
yes we're getting a movie but they also
confirmed that it's not necessarily
going straight to cinema they said that
that decision has not actually been made
just yet they are obviously doing all
that development work all that
preparation work and the decision
whether it will go to cinema or
streaming basically will be made in the
next few weeks
now at the time the wga The Writer's
Guild of America's strike agreement
hadn't been made basically now the
writer's Guild has got a tentative
agreement with the
um actual Studios and it looks like
they're going to be able to get back to
work quite quickly I suspect however
though that the studios knew that this
was going to be relatively likely and
that's why she's talking about the next
few weeks to make that decision I
suspect so what else was this Source
able to tell me well I asked is there a
script and they confirmed yes there is a
script for the movie it has gone through
a period of development and it is pretty
much ready for the project moving
forwards I asked if Mark Fergus from
penguin and Parker wrote that script I
got a right smile I'm told that they
cannot confirm nor deny I got a couple
of those so just wait
I asked whether a director had been
picked and we actually discussed rumors
that I've been sharing with you guys
that actually one was picked and that
name was Jordan peel who's done a couple
of quite High concept um you know Sci-Fi
movies and horrors of late the source
was able to confirm to me again that yes
those conversations did happen and that
was true but they are not going ahead
with Jordan pee on for the director of
this and even though that they know who
the director is going to be that that
has not been finalized just yet so
I pushed this and sort of said like who
is it have they signed on is it sort of
official or you know as a contract been
signed and the source said again all I
can say is all I can confirm is that we
know who the director will be now I'm
going to read between the lines here a
little again and I have to confirm again
this is my opinion but I suspect that
while the strike is going on a lot of
directors have been sort of working in
solidarity with the writers and the
actors and don't necessarily want to
sign contracts they don't mind having
those conversations and they're
perfectly allowed to they don't come
under any of the strike rules of the
actors and the um writers have been sort
of refusing to really sign anything
so I suspect that's a similar type of
thing or perhaps as I understand it
actually the Jordan peel thing didn't
fall through till quite recently so
perhaps they just haven't actually got
to the legal Point yet the source though
really excitingly was able to tell me
that a TV series will 100 be following
the movie
they basically said this has already
been green lit it's already been agreed
it is happening so that really does
reassure that a lot of fans that it
really doesn't matter how well or how
poorly the movie does we're going to be
getting the series that actually we
really really want Amazon have always
seen Stargate as a big part of the
reason why they bought MGM The Source
was again able to confirm that in our
conversation they've said look James
Bond was the main reason why Amazon were
interested in MGM that is the most
valuable asset MGM owns but Stargate was
always in the conversation and Stargate
have always had the plan of moving
forwards with a big Stargate franchise
it's going to be something that Jenny
stiven and MGM Insider called a tent
Paul franchise and by that it means that
it's going to be something that Amazon
really do hang lots of other things off
that it's going to be movies it's going
to be cinema movies perhaps streaming
movies miniseries longer seasons
something prequels whatever that
Stargate really is going to be a project
that Amazon have plans for for the next
decade not just a wham bam thank you
ma'am movie but actually a much bigger
idea and that is very exciting obviously
all of these plans can change at the end
of the day if the movie comes out and
does really really badly
any businessman on the planet would
maybe reconsider their options but it
does seem at the moment that Amazon are
pretty confident and that should give
fans at least a little bit of confidence
so the moment I've got to be really
careful what I say this Source has
basically said that look if we work
together well we're going to be able to
share other information with you maybe
even the odd little exclusive but I've
got to play ball with them I've
basically got to do as I'm told on this
or they'll cut ties and they'll go to
somebody else so again I apologize there
are certain things I just can't tell you
at the moment but hopefully I'll be able
to soon finally what the source did
again confirm to me is that yes they
were very very close to announcing this
at San Diego Comic-Con something I was
telling you before Christmas they never
actually went as far as planning
anything because they realized very
early on apparently that again they
weren't going to be able to do it but
was the intention and that tells me that
they were very very close to actually an
announcement now they need to have three
things in line before they can announce
they need a script they need a director
and they need a leading man or woman an
actor to stand up on stage and take a
bow when they make the announcement now
they may just announce the intention and
in that case they don't need those three
things but to make a really big
spectacle to make a really big splash to
really get people excited they really do
need those three things and it would
seem we've got at least two of them
because the source is confirmed it we
only need that third one and maybe
just maybe we could get a big
announcement and one of the Comic Cons
that's coming up between now and
Christmas I would absolutely love to see
this get announced on a big stage I
think that's something that Stargate
deserves and I think it would be very
very cool it would be a shame in a way
if it was just a you know announcement
via a website somewhere the strikes have
kind of ruined a lot of those plans
because a lot of the Comic Cons happened
in the summer
so let's see what they decide it's
really really exciting that I actually
actually have access to a source here
that is a pretty high up executive I've
never been able to talk to sources at
that sort of level before you know my
sources are you know like admin and you
know like the janitor and things like
that they've been able to get me some
amazing information exclusively and
before everybody else but actually now
to be able to ask questions and actually
maybe even get some exclusive
information from people that are
actually making the decisions
that is really exciting I have obviously
confirmed that the person I'm speaking
to is the person that they say they are
I have to admit my first instinct was
someone's trying to play me for a fool
but they are who they say they are and
the um executive in charge they do work
for them I've been able to confirm that
through well basically an internet
search but also a couple of sources that
I'm reasonably close to this have been
able to again confirm that they are who
they say they are so we can be really
confident this information is accurate
we can be really confident that Stargate
is about to reopen we can be really
confident that at least six Chevrons are
locked and that the set of the Chevron
is about to get locked we're getting a
movie
maybe at the cinema we're definitely get
a TV series immediately after there is
definitely a script and they have a
director
now it's just that announcement that's
all we're waiting for and now the
strikes are coming to an end
it could literally be weeks
but let's wait and see so guys tell me
what you think are you happy that this
is finally getting some really solid
Clarity that we're actually getting
words from MGM even if it is sort of
through the back door a little bit and
really all we're waiting for now is that
final announcement Amazon and MGM seem
to be laying that groundwork getting a
few of the YouTubers out there that are
talking about Stargate a lot on board
early on they're obviously doing that as
a bit of a charm offensive but what do
you think is that a good plan and you
know
does it again give you that a little bit
more confidence that MGM and Amazon are
actually serious about this but get into
the comments and tell me exactly what
you think
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack where most of our new
videos air first and you get to see them
without the adverts for a small
contribution each month that really
supports the channel also you can go to
sidetrack.co.uk where we do articles
based on most of our videos and we try
to add a little bit more information in
there for you to digest please go check
it out as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next time foreign
foreign